so once again we find ourselves in a
scenario where we need a bunch of
costumes in a short amount of time
problem with this video is that although
it's only a page and a half on paper
there are something like 25 characters
each one basically comes in does one
thing and then goes out of the seat you
got to account for the amount of time it
takes for the same person to get in and
out of costume ten times unique did a
great job making the Captain America
shield he did that in a pinch made that
happen in a day right now our plan a is
we kind of like this PVC piece put on
top of this foam piece and I creates the
full thickness of the shield wide up I
wanted to crush no that's not my place
to question
now I wanted him to make one because
Captain America is a popular character
whenever you have a chance to make
something for a video that you may use
again in another video just go ahead and
make it
laugh it up with the matter
hey wolf life called Breaking Bad
I'm Jesse Matt what are you doing I'm
gonna just hate this shield black so I
can paint blue and red white it's
America man very often it's easy to get
confused instead you're doing the first
part of horse and the last part of
horses we have a bunch of characters to
get militiamen in America and then
obi-wan Kenobi Darth Vader be brave come
back we're now finishing at the end
where it's Hillary we have Donald Trump
lay down you're gonna have to shave we
have to cut off me I'm gonna cut them no
what do you mean no I don't want to lose
my toughest are you ready yeah now is it
gonna hurt I'm just looking right now
I'm so ready
you looking rosy dude I think people
will understand how mostly all right cut
them out no more Mexicans bugging me Sam
give me a couple more those like spaz
moment okay at least yeah I'd love to
get like real vocalization here pic
moments and turn them into full-on
character B's fishing off three two one
action
ah what scared myself because he scared
me my face I don't step on anything
great works with you those incredible
mm-hmm you know like when you pop it
stuff with fishing liners it's like a
special type of string you use called
cinema string got like gap tape you know
it's like the special string that for
only professionals use on set as you can
see here this is cinema quality string
so yeah only work with the best three
two one go
they needed a character who is wise
mature and handsome they couldn't find
that person so they got me to be obi-wan
buff dude Hudson's got the perfect hair
and facial complexion to play obi-wan
Kenobi so it was kind of a no-brainer in
between takes the corridor crew just
kind of keeps me a little bit isolated
by myself you know because I start
getting hungry at Manzi too young
favorite person that we work with a lot
on costume she's also a part-time
cosplayer she's got a great lady sonic
costume so we hit her up then we reached
out to some guys out of Utah called
freaking rad had an awesome Iron Man
costume and a really cool Captain
America costume they came out all the
way from Utah just to help us out and be
in the video so thank you guys if you'd
like our stuff you'll definitely like
theirs check it out
freakin rad
this is full 1% hand we're trying to
avoid showing my face in this job this
is just pure carnage nice and close you
can see the blame on the damage alright
there's door in the X we like just
running through it like breaking it as
you run I'm scared I'm gonna hurt myself
there's dust of my eyes so how do you
feel oh yeah okay let's sit down at some
point today for you bring me up to speed
on music I'm assuming Ren's just to be
full-on taking over the effects exactly
you've got a great grasp on that right
now it's moving along very smoothly I
don't see any issues I think we're on
the same page with everyone part of me
is like three is done before July 4th
could be kind of cool to release it the
day before didn't launch akasagarbha
fighting yeah before July so I don't
know what do you guys think I didn't
throw that out there it's not in time
yeah okay first of all Cookie Monster is
just devouring Elmo so I've got blood
and stuff flying off and it's really
gross
it came up with this really good idea I
was so brutal I had to include it he was
like what if you added some bows i sling
fly off so I'm in the process of adding
that now we'll see how it is in a few
moments plane moves yeah
I've doing some shadow animation
animation jitter and just pretty much
draw the same things few times it's
never gonna look the same so it gives us
a little jitter it looks pretty cool I
like it so contrary to popular beliefs
we don't actually have that much money
to make videos so we don't really have
the luxury of being like oh yeah we'll
use a bunch of different Master Chief
costumes that are different colors so
our master chief costume is just greens
the classics Chiefy green we had to go
through and change the colors of the
shots surprise since here is one shot
where you need to change him to being
red here's the issue there's a lot of
other stuff in the background that is
green there's a lot of other stuff in
the background that has very similar
luminance values they're kind of the
same brightness
even though Niko is really really good
at color correcting the best he could do
was basically shift everything to a red
like parts of the sky is red all the
bushes are red and we want only the
armor to be red to do that we had to do
what's called a proto scoping and rotor
scoping is where you go through frame by
frame and literally just snip out all
the different shots it's not a
particularly difficult task but it is
notorious for being super tedious and
not fun so here's the final shot where
we've rotoscoped everything that is not
the armor out including the gun so now
we have what is essentially Simmons from
the web series red vs. blue for the Elmo
and Cookie Monster sound effects I
actually just wanted to use the real
sounds I was watching Sesame Street
episodes I was just looking for
basically an episode of Elmo that has
great lines that can be taken out of
context guess what elmo is thinking
about to get 18 segments what the hell
is that what what use that way when you
get squished black man so I just got an
email from Bernie with the final audio
for both him in Simmons through their
own special little filter pass too so we
have it actually sounding like it's from
the
rather than just raw audio which is
great because I don't know the filters
that they used to make him sound like
radio units inside their helmets a
little bit bland a little bit forests
and then compressor cuz I guarantee you
they have presets where they just drag
and drop so now that I got the
roosterteeth voiceovers the last thing I
need to do for sound design is mix it to
the final track music add some
sweeteners so basically cinematic sound
whooshes bass drops stuff like that and
then a final mix paroles done it's 6:30
and the slow going to be exporting in
half our dope I'm almost done color
grading sound is all finished we are
putting the final touches and all the
little doodads on the video that you do
before you export so I wanna give a
shout out to our friend max max Gorelick
is the man who made the music for this
piece and he actually did the song for
the order 1986 he did a great job at it
and he did a great job on this to his
YouTube channel is youtube.com slash I
wish I was finished check them out